[Musica]
quando è stata l'ultima volta che vi
siete sentiti vulnerabili beh per me
credo che sia esattamente adesso nel mio
lavoro come sarta e come consulente
d'immagine
mi trovo ad operare con un tessuto molto
complesso e molto prezioso l'essere
umano per la precisione mi trovo ad
operare sia con il singolo tessuto
individuale di un essere umano sia con
il tessuto collettivo che chiamiamo moda
e la consulente d'immagine
a ben guardare è un po l'anti moda
perché l'interesse primario che una
persona si senta bene nella sua pelle
al di là di un modello ideale da seguire
quindi è una professione è certo che a
che fare con la consulenza di immagine
ma quindi con l'immagine ma
contrariamente a quello che si potrebbe
pensare sa più che fare con il senso di
identità che con l'estetica
a proposito di identità mi ha sempre
affascinato il nome stesso che ci siamo
dati come specie esseri umani appunto
per le altre specie
non usiamo nome di questo tipo non
diciamo essere rosaceo per definire una
rosa invece per noi come specie ci siamo
dotati di un nome composto in quella
parte davvero interessante secondo me
sta nell'aggettivo umano infatti non è
solo una condizione di nascita una
qualità naturale ma è soprattutto una
direzione di scopo una qualità in
potenza che va sviluppata e quindi ci
siamo dotati di un nome che contempla
natura e scelta insieme e questo è molto
interessante perché già in pieno
rinascimento uno come pico della
mirandola parlava dell'essere umano come
soggetto che si trova in ogni momento a
decidere se essere un bruto o un essere
celeste per lavoro mi trovo
costantemente a maneggiare l'identità
degli altri
per la precisione mi trovo costantemente
sullo spartiacque tra una vecchia
identità
magari logora e una nuova o perlomeno il
suo desiderio
in quel momento quando le persone
arrivano da me fragili in una fase di
cambiamento di crisi
il mio ruolo deve essere
fondamentalmente maieutico un po come lo
intendeva socrate cioè io faccio per
loro da levatrice da ostetrica la mia
via essenzialmente una via femminile
perché privilegia il contenimento alla
penetrazione per spiegarmi meglio io non
faccio come un hacker
io non entro nei sistemi io tesse una
tela
mi aspetto che sia la stessa persona
scoprire dentro di sé sa aspetti che non
aveva considerato e poi insieme
riportiamo alla luce e facciamo in modo
di comunicarli all'esterno con un
linguaggio essenzialmente e visivo ma
l'identità esiste ma io non ho mai vista
una che cammina quindi ontologicamente
direi di no non esiste però ci serve
come concetto in questo mondo per
sentirci visti scelti voluti un po come
quando si sceglie un nome per un bambino
che deve nascere e come tutti i nomi può
diventare anche una gabbia se ci
crediamo troppo
cioè se lo usiamo come antidoto alla
paura ray kurzweil grande genio grande
entusiasta dell'intelligenza artificiale
nel suo libro la singolarità è vicina
ci parla del fatto che a breve le
intelligenze artificiali ci
permetteranno di superare la nostra
biologicità e lui intende questa cosa
della biologicità come un grosso limite
dell'essere umano ma nella mia
esperienza quotidiana personale con gli
esseri umani vedo invece che proprio la
fragilità
l'elemento fondamentale in quei momenti
di passaggio perché finalmente
sono le maschere e viene fuori qualcosa
di autentico da un essere umano e si
intravede finalmente quella bellezza che
prima era totalmente nascosta
allora nella grande sfida di corse la
superamento della biologicità ci
perderemmo quello che ha
il gioiello dell'essere umano cioè la
sua vulnerabilità non come dato assoluto
in sé ma per come ti fa pensare
comportare quel tuo sentirti fragile gli
esseri umani sono umani e si ricordano
di esserlo solo quando fanno esperienza
fisica proprio della loro fragilità
allora quando è stata l'ultima volta che
vi siete sentiti vulnerabili ciascuno di
noi avrà la sua risposta personale
intima ecco quello è stato l'ultimo
momento in cui vi siete sentiti davvero
umani in cui vi è stata regalata la
possibilità per ripensare a voi stessi e
di darvi eventualmente una nuova
direzione
oggi va molto di moda simmons in sé che
il suo golden circle quello che dice che
bisogna partire in tutte le cose
domandandosi il perché è solo dopo
chiedere come cosa bene lui intende il
perché come credo bil'in motivazione
profonda
bene io penso che la nostra
vulnerabilità da vulnus la parola latina
che significa ferita ci apra
direttamente alla nostra vocazione più
che stati guai come dice sì next ci
metterei statue pound cioè ricominciamo
dalla ferita o dal difetto presunto le
ferite si burlano in un certo senso
fanno lo sgambetto alle nostre abilità
razionali e ci costringono a mettere in
campo risorse che in un certo senso non
sapevamo neanche di avere il concetto di
vulnerabilità assomiglia tantissimo
a quello tutto biologico di permeabilità
dalle ferite infatti possono sgorgare
ideali emozioni valori ma può anche
entrare inaspettatamente il nostro vero
progetto di vita in una sorta di dialogo
osmotico continuo tra espressione e
conoscenza insieme le ferite
dell'identità se vogliamo sono le più
dolorose proprio perché ci fanno tremare
il terreno sotto i piedi
non sappiamo più chi siamo e oggi
l'esperienza dell'intelligenza
artificiale sta facendo un po questo a
tutti noi cioè sta mettendo in dubbio
quel primato che noi credevamo essere
nostro per diritto di evoluzione
naturale ceci scalzano dal podio degli
esseri più intelligenti del pianeta e
questo è terribile perché mettendo in
dubbio la nostra identità ci fanno
sentire da vicino
l'odore della morte ma lo stesso tempo è
bellissimo è un momento potenzialmente
molto fertile per noi come specie e come
individui l'aratro ingegnerizzazione del
cervello cioè appunto la che raggio del
nostro pensiero per tradurre nel
funzionamento biologico in algoritmi che
poi faranno funzionare i robot è
paragonabile in tutto e per tutto ad un
nuovo umanesimo
magari non avrà il fascino della firenze
artistico letteraria di lorenzo il
magnifico ma come allora ci permette di
ripensare a noi stessi in sostanza di
darci un nuovo nome e una nuova
interpretazione della nostra identità e
questa volta abbiamo il grande
privilegio di poterla reinterpretare
anche facendo tesoro di elezioni come
quella di stefano mancuso incredibile
scienziato che nei suoi libri ci ha
fatto capire come esistano il mondo
essere assolutamente intelligenti ma che
noi non avevamo mai considerato davvero
intelligenti perché diversi da noi
magari privi di un elaboratore centrale
con un cervello o magari talmente lenti
nella loro evoluzione
da non poter essere facilmente ha
seguiti dai nostri strumenti di
percezione cioè le piante il mondo
vegetale e allora proprio recependo
questo tipo di elezioni oggi abbiamo la
possibilità di darci una nuova
definizione un nuovo nome che faccia
leva proprio su quella fragilità
biologica che ha il potere di renderci
così belli e di far uscire tutto ciò che
è davvero umano da noi e che ci accomuna
con gli altri esseri qualcosa che suoni
come quelli umani tra gli esseri con gli
altri esseri senza più podi o riflettori
ecco siamo un po nel momento storico
perfetto per operare un sovvertimento di
prospettiva passare cioè dalla
intelligenza artificiale alla saggezza
artificiale e per ripassare di la
dobbiamo fare qualcosa che fino adesso
abbiamo un po tenuto sotto il tappeto
c'è dobbiamo ripassare per cui la
saggezza naturale che non avevamo
considerato come una cosa così
intelligente ma anche invece
fondamentale in sostanza ci servono più
esseri umani integri cioè persone che
oltre all'inter letto che è per sua
natura uno strumento di discernimento
quindi dettaglio potremmo dire sappiano
anche usare strumenti di unificazione
strumenti che sono da sempre umani come
per esempio la vita la vitalità la
presenza alla vita quindi la cura
l'attenzione per la vita la coscienza
cioè la consapevolezza dei processi che
ci circondano e di noi stessi e per
finire la grande rimozione del ventesimo
secolo che è il sentire
siamo abituati a pensare che se una cosa
la sentiamo ma non sappiamo spiegarla
non sappiamo dire il perché non esista
in un certo senso nascerà umani non
basta più serve diventarlo
la rosa è senza per che fiorisce per che
fiorisce non va da sé e non si cura di
essere guardata questa immagine poetica
di un mistico del 1600 di nome angelus
silesius ed essenzialmente come esseri
umani siamo chiamati a fiorire cioè
realizzare la nostra natura profonda
anche accettando di uscire dal perché
c'è dalla sfera della razionalità della
mera utilità
con buona pace di cena e la rosa è senza
perché e non va da sé perché la sua
fioritura corrisponde alla sua vocazione
profonda e riesce a trascendersi in un
certo senso mentre fiorisce in un pone
attenzione ai suoi confini attuali
mentre lo fa ma si fida del suo fiorire
magari anche senza capirlo e non le
importa di essere guardata perché
appunto il suo fiorire corrisponde alla
sua vocazione profonda e non ad un
obiettivo indotto dall esterno
la grande differenza tra la rosa cioè la
vita e l'intelligenza artificiale sta
nel fatto che la seconda cioè
l'intelligenza artificiale è fatalmente
ingabbiata nella storia e per di più
solo nella storia dell'essere umano
la realtà è che un parto della nostra
mente non potrà mai stupirti come un
figlio
perché un tuo prodotto e non una
creatura libera è diverso da te e
dall'idea che hai di te stesso
chiudo facendo qualcosa che normalmente
non si vede fare ad un tag cioè provo
cantare una canzone che parla di un nome
e di un'identità
io tengo molto a questa canzone perché è
nata in un momento che definirei essere
quello di massima fragilità per me è di
massima vulnerabilità umana perché
quando ho avuto mia figlia appena dopo
il parto
ho sperimentato alcuni attacchi di
panico
ecco in quei momenti la mente razionale
va completamente in tilt e tu
semplicemente sei convinta che stai per
morire
poi non succede ma se convinta e ho
scoperto però che proprio il massimo
momento di vulnerabilità può
trasformarsi nel massimo momento di
umanità e creatività
anche allora in quei momenti in cui
tutto ciò che volevo era lasciare
qualcosa mia figlia è nato un po quello
che io chiamo il testamento emotivo che
io lascio a lei si chiama celeste
attraverso il racconto del suo nome ecco
oggi vorrei dedicare questa canzone a
tutti noi fragili emotivi vulnerabili
come siamo a finti e impariamo ad usare
il nostro nome personale come mappa
quindi non come previsione di un destino
già segnato ma come strumento di viaggio
in cui la direzione va costruita giorno
per giorno e vorrei dedicarla anche
all'esperienza dell'intelligenza
artificiale affinché ci permetta come
specie di lasciare un po morire la
nostra vecchia identità ormai logora e
di incarnare davvero il nome che già ci
siamo dati cioè esseri umani
[Musica]
era da tanto ormai da tanto
io lo so
ma la voce cantava qualcosa ma capiva
ma il tuo nome
altro nome non mi viene occorre una
parola
penso proprio
vorrei
che non ti definì modo per vivere una
barca
[Musica]
no
e marina
nico cercato il tuo nome mi ha riempito
la bocca lo grido
[Musica]
ce l'ha
il tuo amore
[Musica]
all'estero
che odore
[Musica]
e blu
il cuore
[Musica]
certe
ma come appunto
pensarci prima
[Musica]
metti appoggia sulla cima quando arrivi
stanco e sudato
tutto quello che posso lasciarla
di tutte le moto e di tutte le mamme era
spero che
[Musica]
le cose
e ancora bianca
di colpo tutto quello che cercavo il
ricordo il tuo nome mi ha riempito la
bocca lo grida
[Applauso]
il colore
se il tuo savoia
per me
nel po
[Musica]
a vestire
vuoi abbracciare
da capire
non solo
[Musica]
mamma
[Applauso]